la france championne d'europe d'abandons
d'animaux
c'est le triste constat de l'association
30 millions d'amis dans sa dernière
campagne choc en 2019 des animaux
abandonnés avant les vacances d'été
ça ne date pas d'hier en 1978
ce vétérinaire de la spa alerter sur la
saturation des centres d'accueil pour
animaux pendant les vacances la plus
mauvaise c'est le mois de juillet est
principalement les quinze derniers jours
de juillet ont vraiment les gens
m'adorent tous qu'ils ne peuvent pas
emmener en vacances qu'ils soient chan o
cha tous nous arrive à ce moment là dans
les années 80
quatre cent mille animaux de compagnie
étaient abandonnés chaque année en
france parmi eux des animaux abandonnés
en pleine nature mais aussi laissé par
leur propriétaire dans des centres
d'accueil bungert année nous c'est gelé
prise est loin du compte mais je sais je
les prie charamel ça je suis tranquille
mais je veux dire c'est pas un succès
c'est parce que l'on creuse où les noms
mais je regrette rien franchement en
1994 exercer un acte de cruauté sur un
animal était puni par la loi de six mois
d'emprisonnement et 50 mille francs
d'amendé en 2006 la loi est modifiée se
durcit abandonner un animal est
considéré comme un acte de cruauté et ça
peut coûter très cher à la pratique est
courante et pourtant la loi est sévère
jusqu'à deux ans d'emprisonnement et 30
mille euros damende malgré une loi
renforcer l'action des associations de
nombreux animaux reste abandonné avant
l'été toutes les générations sont
concernés par ce problème
alors pour sensibiliser les plus jeunes
à l'abandon la spa se rendait
directement dans les écoles à la
rencontre des élèves en 2007 on court
une sensibilisation pendant deux heures
pour faire prendre conscience de leurs
actes à ses élèves de 6e
face à la souffrance animale si le
nombre d'abandons était de 400 milles il
ya 30 ans il est aujourd'hui 200 milles
dont 60 milles rien qu'en été un chiffre
en baisse
qui fait toujours de l'été la saison la
plus critique en matière d'abandon
[Musique]